ROOTING FOR YOU.
>> THANKS SO MUCH.
>> Tucker: FROM THE EARLY DAYS
OF THE CORONAVIRUS, DOCTORS HAVE
RELAYED PROMISING NEWS ABOUT THE
ANTIMALARIA DRUG
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
THEY CITED THAT DRUG AT
ONE POINT AS POTENTIAL THERAPY.
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT WAS
HELPFUL, THE PRESS WITH THE
OPPOSITE OF THAT.
THEY OPPOSED FINDING A CURE FOR
THE CORONAVIRUS BECAUSE THEY
FEAR TO MAKE OF THE PRESIDENTS
AND POLITICAL ADVANTAGE.
THIS WAS EVERYWHERE.
HERE ARE A FEW EXAMPLES.
"USA TODAY" WROTE THIS,
"DR. DONALD TRUMP PEDALS SNAKE
OIL AND FALSE HOPE."
."
CNN NEEDLESS TO SAY SAID THE
SAME.
"TRUMP PEDALS UNSUBSTANTIATED
HOPE IN DARK TIMES."
OF "THE WASHINGTON POST," A
LOATHSOME PUBLICATION OF A
FAIRLY EVEN A NEWSPAPER NOW,
DECLARED "TRUMP IS GIVING PEOPLE
FALSE COURSE.
IT’S ALL SNAKE OIL."
CLICHES BEING A SPECIALTY OF
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
NONE OF THESE PEOPLE HAD ANY
FREAKING CLUE WHAT THEY WERE
TALKING ABOUT.
IN FACT, THEY WERE THE ONES THAT
WERE PEDDLING UNSUBSTANTIATED
SNAKE OIL.
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE IS STILL
BEING RESEARCHED BUT THIS WILL
TELL YOU A LOT.
DOCTORS WHO WERE ACTUALLY
TREATING PEOPLE WHO WERE SICK
WITH THE CORONAVIRUS SEEM TO
BELIEVE IN IT.
MANY OF THEM DO.
HERE’S HOW WE KNOW THAT.
A GLOBAL SURVEY OF 6200 MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS CURRENTLY
FIGHTING THE CORONAVIRUS
PANDEMIC FOUND THAT
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE WAS THE MOST
FREQUENTLY CITED DRUG THEY WOULD
TURN TO TREAT PATIENTS.
IT HAD THE PLURALITY.
37%.
IT WAS NUMBER 1 OUT OF 15
OPTIONS.
THE BIGGEST BELIEVERS IN
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE WERE NOT
PEOPLE WHO WATCH FOX NEWS OR
EVEN GOVERNED BY DONALD TRUMP
YOU THEY WERE DOCTORS IN SPAIN
AND ITALY, TWO COUNTRIES WHERE
THE EPIDEMIC HAS BEEN THE WORST.
JUST TO LET YOU KNOW
UNEQUIVOCALLY, AND FOR ALL TIME,
THAT THE MEDIA LIED ABOUT A
POTENTIAL THERAPY TO DEFEAT THIS
DISEASE AND SAVE YOUR LIFE
BECAUSE THEY ARE POLITICALLY
PARTISAN.
THAT TELLS YOU EVERYTHING YOU
NEED TO KNOW.
FOX MEDICAL CONTRIBUTOR
DR. MARC SIEGEL JOINS US TONIGHT
BE A THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMING UNPAID WITHOUT DRAGGING
YOU INTO ALL THE CLINICAL
NONSENSE, IT’S NOT YOUR WORLD,
NOT WHERE YOU LIVE, NOT WHERE
YOU WANT TO LIVE, TELL US WHAT
DOCTORS ARE SAYING ABOUT
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
>> HI, TUCKER.
FIRST OF ALL, HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE
HAS BEEN LOOKED AT IN THE TEST
TUBE IN CHINA AND FOUND TO BE
VERY, VERY EFFECTIVE AGAINST
THIS CORONAVIRUS, SPECIFICALLY A
PART OF THE CELL WHERE THE VIRUS
ENTERS.
THAT WAS A VERY STRONG STUDY.
THEN JOHN ALSO HAS SOME
FOLLOW-UP STUDIES WHERE THEY
LOOKED AT THE EFFECTS IN PEOPLE
AND IT HAD SOME EFFECTS ON
PEOPLE.
IN FRANCE, WE TALKED ABOUT A
STUDY IN FRANCE WHICH WAS PRETTY
SMALL BUT SHOWED THAT IT WAS
EFFECTIVE.
NOW, AS YOU SAID, DOCTORS HAVE
BEEN USING IT ALL OVER THE
UNITED STATES, MANY ARE SAYING
THAT IT’S WORKING.
WE’VE SEEN IT IN NEW YORK STATE,
GIVING IT TO HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
RIGHT NOW IN HOSPITALS WITH A
LOT OF PROMISING SIGNS, AND
FINALLY, THE UNIVERSITY OF
PENNSYLVANIA HAS JUST BEGUN A
MAJOR DOUBLE-BLIND, RANDOMIZED,
PROSPECTIVE CLINICAL TRIAL
AND YOU KNOW WHEN THEY DO THAT,
WHEN THEY SPEND THAT KIND OF
MONEY?
WHEN THEY BELIEVE A TREATMENT
MAY WORK.
I CAN’T PROVE TO YOU THAT IT
WORKS AT THIS POINT, BUT IT’S
EXTREMELY PROMISING, AND THERE’S
A LOT OF EVIDENCE THAT IT DOES
WORK.
>> Tucker: THAT’S SO
INTERESTING.
DO YOU THINK, AND THIS IS
POLITICALLY TINGED BUT I CANNOT
RESIST, THE TERRIBLE PUBLICITY
THAT THIS DRUG HAS RECEIVED,
JUST RELENTLESSLY COME OVER THE
PAST THREE WEEKS, THIS IS A
CRACKPOT CURE, THIS IS SNAKE
OIL.
DO YOU THINK THAT HAS MADE
PHYSICIANS HESITANT TO TRY IT AS
A THERAPY?
>> NO, I THINK PHYSICIANS GO
WITH WHAT WORKS.
I THINK THEY’RE FACING A
SITUATION WHERE THEY DON’T KNOW
WHAT OFFER PATIENTS.
PATIENTS ARE GETTING WORSE FOR
THE IDEA THAT THERE IS A DRUG
OUT THERE THAT IS VERY WELL
TOLERATED FOR MALARIA
PROPHYLAXIS AND RHEUMATOID
ARTHRITIS AND LUPUS, THAT THEY
COULD USE IT FOR SOMETHING LIKE
THIS MAKES DOCTORS WANT TO TRY
IT.
>> Tucker: RIGHT, THAT’S
RIGHT.
I THINK A LOT OF US -- I KNOW
I’VE TAKEN ON TRIPS ABROAD TO
MALARIA ZONES, IT’S A COMMON
DRUG.
SO HERE’S A QUESTION I WANTED TO
ASK.
IT IS A MESSAGE YOU SAID HE
WOULD LIKE TO DELIVER TO NURSES
AND DOCTORS TONIGHT FIGHTING THE
CORONAVIRUS.
WHAT IS IT?
>> TALK TO CAIUS KELLY WAS A
NURSE WHO DIED LAST WEEK
TRAGICALLY.
MAY NOT HAVE HAD ENOUGH PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT IN
NEW YORK.
JOHN MURRAY IS A 92-YEAR-OLD
PHYSICIAN WHO HELPED DISCOVER
THE KIND OF LUNG PROBLEM THAT IS
ACTUALLY KILLING PEOPLE FROM
CORONAVIRUS AND HE DIED OF
CORONAVIRUS.
WE’VE BEEN SEEING A LOT OF
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS ON THE
FRONT LINES, EMERGENCY
TECHNICIANS, NURSES, DOCTORS,
OVER 60 DOCTORS IN ITALY HAVE
DIED TRYING TO TREAT THE
COVID-19 CORONAVIRUS.
I’M A MEDICAL STUDENT WHO I
TRAINED AND HE IS NOW GRADUATING
THREE MONTHS EARLY AT NYU
MEDICAL CENTER TO GO ON THE
FRONT LINES TO FIGHT COVID-19.
HE’S REINVESTING HIS SOUL AND
WHY HE WENT INTO MEDICINE IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
HE HAS FEAR, HE IS WORRIED ABOUT
HIS FAMILY, BUT HE IS INVESTING
HIMSELF.
A LOT OF DOCTORS AROUND NEW YORK
RIGHT NOW ARE CHANGING THEIR
PROFESSIONS.
THE GOING FROM BEING AN
ORTHOPEDIST OR BEING RETIRED OR
HAVING BEEN ON THE FRONT LINES,
NOW TO GO TO FIGHT THE VIRUS.
THAT IS THE WAR AGAINST THE
VIRUS.
HEALTH CARE WORKERS, NURSES,
DOCTORS, EMTS, THEY’RE ON THE
FRONT LINES.
PARAMEDICS.
AND WE SHOULD CONGRATULATE THEM
FOR THEIR EFFORTS.
>> Tucker: I COULDN’T AGREE
MORE.
OF THE REST OF US ARE COWERING
IN FEAR, AND WE SHOULD BE
AFRAID, AND THESE PEOPLE ARE
JUMPING FACE FIRST INTO A
SITUATION THAT COULD KILL THEM.
I REALLY ADMIRE THAT.
I THINK WE SHOULD ALL ADMIRE